Hey guys, this is doctor Berg here.
I want to talk about what you must know if
you don't have a gallbladder, okay?
People are told they don't need their gallbladder,
it's an unnecessary organ and you won't have
any problems but there's some long-term effects.
First of all what is the gallbladder?
It's a little sac that hangs underneath your
liver, about the size of a little potato and
there's a tube that comes from your liver
and this little sac that hangs off this tube.
The key is what it holds, what it stores.
The gallbladder stores and holds bile, B-I-L-E.
What is bile?
Bile is the very important fluid that helps
you absorb fats, absorb fatty soluble vitamins,
regulate cholesterol, help balance hormones.
It does a lot, it helps lubricate the colon.
We'll talk about all those but basically without
a gallbladder you don't have the concentrated
effect.
Normally the bile is concentrated by five
times the amount, in that little sac there.
We need that bile to secrete out when you
eat fats to be able to pull that in.
Without that gallbladder you're always going
to be deficient in bile.
It's just going to trickle down, because it's
made by the liver it's going to trickle down.
By the way, bile is what prevents gallstones.
Probably the reason why you had a gallstone
in the first place is you don't have enough
bile.
Now, they take the gallbladder out and you
don't have the bile, you continue to have
other problems.
Let's take a look at, without a gallbladder
all the potential issues.
Number one you're not going to balance the
cholesterol anymore.
Cholesterol is necessary in the building of
hormones, specifically stress hormones but
other hormones too, like testosterone.
They're made from cholesterol, your brain
needs cholesterol, the nerves need cholesterol.
Also free cholesterol needs bile to help break
it down.
You can have more of a buildup of cholesterol
without bile, so we have an imbalance of cholesterol,
the good and bad.
That's number one.
Number two, you may find that you're not actually
eliminating toxins.
Why?
Because the toxins go through this bile duct
when they come and they're eliminated, so
the bile helps in the breakdown of toxins
and the elimination of toxins, not to mention
the lubrication of the colon, so you may end
up with constipation.
The next one is thyroid.
T4, the inactive thyroid hormone is converted
to T3 through the liver and the gallbladder,
without a gallbladder you're thyroid can suffer,
in that it won't convert.
You might end up with a thyroid issue which
affects a whole host of problems because we
need that gallbladder to do the conversion.
The other one is preventing fatty liver, because
the fat can actually build up in the liver
if you don't have the bile, bile breaks down
fat.
Now, if you don't have the fat soluble vitamins,
vitamin A the vision suffers, you won't be
able to see at night when you're driving in
the dark.
The vision just kind of goes down, you need
vitamin A in general for your vision.
The skin becomes dry, you have issues with
skin, the inner skin of the inner sinuses
become a problem, sinus problems, sleep apnea,
immune system, that's all vitamin A. Vitamin
D is the regulation of calcium.
You may find that your calcium is off, especially
the metabolism of calcium, you get bone pain,
you have issues with the immune system, things
like that.
Also in people who are low in vitamin D, they
have problems with depression during the winter
time because they don't have enough vitamin
D. Vitamin D is also good to prevent asthma
as well.
Okay, vitamin E, very essential for the heart.
Vitamin E increases the oxygen to the heart
by 250%.
That actually increases oxygen to the heart
to prevent heart cramps, it's great as an
anti-angina nutrient.
Vitamin E is also called the anti-sterility,
so it prevents becoming sterile, it helps
fertility.
Vitamin E is important in the skin, so many
women use it on their skin, vitamin E oil.
Now we've got vitamin K1, that's to prevent
bruising and to help clotting.
Vitamin K2 prevents the soft tissue calcium
from building up in the arteries, in the joints,
very, very important.
There's even certain phytonutrients, like
plant based chemicals in the cruciferous vegetables
that are fat soluble too.
We have Lycopene, Lutein, Carotenoids, those
are all fat soluble, those are all very, very
important in protecting the eye, protecting
it against macular degeneration, just helping
you see in general.
Those are fat soluble.
Then, also you're not going to absorb the
omega 3 fatty acids, think about why you need
omega 3 fatty acids?
That's all anti-inflammatory, I mean it's
precursor's to build body tissue, so many
issues.
These are a small list of potential issues
that you could have if you don't have a gallbladder,
okay?
I hope that gave you some enlightenment.
The question is what do you do if you don't
have a gallbladder?
Well, what I would recommend is to take some
type of bile support to supplement your body
so when you eat you have enough bile to prevent
these issues.
You have to realize that it's going to be
a slow process, it doesn't happen overnight.
You may see symptoms months after the gallbladder's
removed.
All right, thanks for watching.
I'll see you in the next videos.